[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
áfrica siete días aquí en france 24 este
es un magacín informativo 100% dedicado
al continente africano mi nombre de
liliana valència que damos una mirada en
profundidad a los hechos de actualidad
de la semana en la cuna de la humanidad
falleció el presidente de tanzania son
pago full y a causa de una afección
cardíaca el mandatario había declarado
la erradicación del coi 19 del país
desde mediados de 2020 la hasta ahora
vicepresidenta también su julio asumió
el mando y se convirtió en la primera
mujer presidente de este país no se
concentra en la lista de países que
buscan legalizar el uso del cannabis
medicinal el país norteafricano aprobó
un proyecto de ley que pretende regular
el cultivo y la comercialización de la
hierba con el objetivo de combatir el
narcotráfico y la organización
internacional save the children emitió
un informe según el cual menores de
hasta 11 años estarían siendo
decapitados en mozambique en la
violencia yihadista en el país ha dejado
más de 600 mil desplazados
iniciamos entonces con la información
aquí en áfrica siete días y empezamos
hablando de tanzania porque el pasado 17
de marzo falleció el presidente sol mago
fu lee de 61 años debido a una
insuficiencia cardíaca mago full y era
uno de los mandatarios más escépticos
con respecto a la pandemia de ccoo y 19
y no hacía apariciones públicas desde
febrero pasado la hasta ahora
vicepresidenta a sanz ya su julio
juramento como nueva mandataria de
tangshan y haciendo historia como la
primera mujer en la jefatura de estado
de dicha nación africana y se espera que
se mantenga en el cargo al menos hasta
a sus 61 años sam ya salió jugadas e
historia esta economista que nació en
sanciveri que se desempeñaba como
vicepresidenta de tanzania se convirtió
este 19 de marzo en la primera jefa de
estado de su nación desde la residencia
presidencial ubicada en la capital
económica de este país africano llamó a
los ciudadanos a defender los valores
constitucionales
este es el momento de enterrar nuestras
diferencias como país y ser uno como
nación es hora de consolarnos o
mostrarnos amor unidad mantener nuestra
paz a nuestra humanidad y patriotismo y
los valores de tanzania
la líder que cuenta con más de 20 años
de trayectoria política llegó a la
jefatura de estado tras la muerte del
mandatario john mago juli que se produjo
a causa de una afección cardíaca el 17
de marzo
las normas tan sanas se estipulan que en
caso de que fallezca el presidente será
el siguiente en la línea de mando quien
asuma las funciones la nueva mandataria
figura como la segunda mujer en ocupar
una jefatura de estado en territorio
africano tras la etíope sale work zewde
se espera que el cuerpo del fallecido
mago fu lee quien negaba la existencia
del cobo y 19 se ha sepultado de este 25
de marzo en château su pueblo natal tras
el desarrollo de varios homenajes en su
memoria y es que el fallecido presidente
mao pulí fue uno de los grandes
escépticos con respecto al coi 19
rechazó confinamientos y suministros de
vacunas en abril de 2020 en plena crisis
sanitaria mago fu lee afirmó que
tanzania había erradicado el coronavirus
mediante tres días de oración nacional y
entonces no hay recuento de casos
confirmados ni de fallecidos por el
virus el turismo en el archipiélago de
zanzíbar está más vivo que nunca vemos
este informe nuestro corresponsal en
sudáfrica salín falla
el archipiélago tanzano de zanzíbar en
áfrica oriental parece ser de los pocos
destinos donde el turismo sigue
prosperando a pesar de la pandemia de
kobe 19 y gran parte de nuestras
comunidades locales tienen empleo ahora
porque en sanz y bar
esta es nuestra principal fuente de
ingresos
así que si deciden cerrar las fronteras
y no permitir que los turistas vengan la
gente va a morir de hambre
sin mascarillas sin distanciamiento sin
toque te quedan mil confinamientos miles
de turistas sobre todo de países
europeos bajo confinamiento y en
invierno llegan a la isla del océano
índico uno de los principales destinos
turísticos del continente africano
por tierra mientras que no como usted
que llega del corte
cuando pasa a ser la vengo de un país
que está bajo un fuerte confinamiento
he estado en mi casa durante un año eso
me destruyó destruyó mi cerebro así que
tome la decisión de salir y venir aquí
como quiera el gobierno tan sano sin
evidencia científica ha declarado al
país libre de kobe y desde mediados de
2020 eliminó todas las medidas de
prevención argumentando que las
enfermedades se pueden curar con
oraciones y con infusiones de hierbas
locales en un periodo en el que a nivel
global se evitan las multitudes en
tanzania las fiestas y eventos no se han
detenido
el abogado y régimen esa en sala que ha
visto morir a 20 de sus colegas es de
los pocos que se ha pronunciado
públicamente
no queremos que el gobierno reconozca el
hecho de que el coronavirus existe en
tanzania que la gente está muriendo a
causa de ello y sufriendo a causa de
ello y necesitamos que se tome acción el
gobierno debería ser contundente en
implementar las medidas de prevención
aplicarlas y al mismo tiempo debe estar
en capacidad de realizar las pruebas
llevó tu conap duchas el presidente de
tanzania john mago juli uno de los
grandes escépticos de la pandemia murió
el 17 de marzo a los 61 años según las
fuentes oficiales a causa de
complicaciones cardíacas se espera que
sus sucesoras amia zulú hassan de un
giro de 180 grados a la gestión de la
pandemia en el país según afirmaron
tanto analistas políticos como la
organización mundial de la salud
también falleció el principal día de la
oposición de la república del congo
guybrush parfait con la quien
participaba en las elecciones
presidenciales que tiene lugar en este
país las elecciones del 21 de marzo con
la de 61 años tuvo que hacer evacuado en
un avión hospital rumbo a parís tratar
positivo por ccoo y 19 poco antes de
aterrizar sucedió su deceso según
confirmó su jefe de campaña citado por
medios locales el propio candidato había
dicho previamente que luchaba contra la
muerte
mis queridos compatriotas estoy luchando
contra la muerte pero les pido que se
levanten vayan y voten por el cambio del
mundo
para que no esté luchando en vano
funciones por cambiamos de información
porque el congreso en marruecos aprobó
un proyecto de ley que pretende regular
el cultivo y comercialización del
cannabis para usos terapéuticos e
industriales la propuesta pretende
impulsar la economía del país y poner un
freno al narcotráfico
justamente marruecos en el norte de
áfrica es el mayor productor de
marihuana a nivel mundial
encaminados a la legalización tras una
semana de la aprobación del proyecto de
ley que permite la producción
exportación y el uso de cannabis con
fines terapéuticos en marruecos los
cultivadores consideran por primera vez
salir de la ilegalidad
la temporada de cosecha se lleva a cabo
en junio y julio y el proceso de
transformación es hachís empieza en
septiembre el traficante de drogas viene
a comprar la producción del agricultor
ofreciendo el precio que él quiere el
agricultor es pobre y la planta es lo
único que crece aquí porque hace
demasiado frío la tierra no es apta para
cereales no es lo suficientemente fértil
tenemos pequeñas parcelas de tierra a
través del proyecto de ley el gobierno
pretende organizar a los cultivadores en
cooperativas y sancionar a quienes
distribuyan la planta por fuera del
circuito oficial
tenemos miedo como agricultores y
pedimos que se establezcan industrias
que transformen el cannabis para su voz
su médico e industrial y que se
establezcan fábricas para emplear mano
de obra local
pese a las divisiones políticas que ha
generado el proyecto de ley el
parlamento deberá ratificar la decisión
del ejecutivo antes de las elecciones
nativas de septiembre con 47 mil
hectáreas de marihuana sembrada en las
montañas del rif marruecos es uno de los
principales productores de marihuana en
el mundo según la agencia antidrogas de
la onu
menores de hasta 11 años estarían siendo
decapitados en mozambique según una
alarmante denuncia la organización save
the children en una región rica en
materias primas donde según las
organizaciones internacionales se están
llevando a cabo crímenes de guerra
perpetrados por facciones yihadistas
los niños están siendo blanco en el
conflicto yihadista que perdura en el
norte de mozambique menores de hasta 11
años han sido decapitados en la
provincia de cabo delgado a manos de la
filial local del autodenominado estado
islámico según denuncia a la
organización save the children else a
una madre de 28 años vio cómo asesinaban
a su hijo philip de 12 esa noche nuestro
pueblo fue atacado y se quemaron casas
cuando todo empezó estaba en casa con
mis cuatro hijos intentamos escapar al
bosque pero se llevaron a mi hijo mayor
y lo decapitaron no pudimos hacer nada
porque también nos matarían a nosotros
al menos 670 mil personas están ahora
desplazadas dentro del país debido a
conflicto en la región norteña una
situación que se ha intensificado
dramáticamente en el último año las
cifras son casi siete veces mayores con
la escalada de ataques a las aldeas la
mayoría de desplazados huyen a pemba
capital de la provincia en busca de
refugios otros viven en lugares
temporales pero el hambre está llevando
a muchos mozambiqueños a arriesgar sus
vidas emprendiendo la travesía de vuelta
a sus antiguas aldeas para recolectar
alimentos
no nos apetece estar aquí
aquí la pueden poner cubiertas en las
casas pueden traer transporte estrellas
y aviones pueden traer todo
lo que queremos es estar en nuestra casa
la tierra donde nacimos y el conflicto
yihadista comenzó en octubre de 2017 en
cabo delgado hogar de la insurgencia
desde entonces la violencia e
inseguridad no ha parado de crecer en
una región estratégica por su riqueza de
piedras preciosas y gas natural pero
donde más de 13 millones de personas
necesitan ayuda alimentaria y más de
950.000 se enfrentan a una hambruna
severa según naciones unidas
y finalizamos con cultura en áfrica
siete días porque cada 21 de marzo se
conmemora el día internacional de la
lucha contra la discriminación
una vez mary de que ha tomado relevancia
para la diáspora africana a nivel
mundial para esta fecha el rapero y
productor afro cubano roberto álvarez
lanzó su nuevo videoclip titulado negro
un canto de identidad y orgullo afro que
ya el viral en europa y en américa
latina en 324 hablamos con el que ahora
la familia y el que llegue uno del niño
directamente a la habana agua diciendo
te estás súper orgulloso de que esté
saliendo en su vídeo negro en este vídeo
que hicimos mostrar varias partes de lo
que significan otras partes no doradas
de la cultura negra y parte de lo que
soy yo destruyera representar lavandería
o el estilismo negro de la
representación de varias culturas y
varios estilos desde gente negra la
representación de la rumba la
representación del baile la música las
telas ones
ahora este tipo de forma de vestir
y la energía que desprenden toda fiesta
negra nos tratamos como de resultarles o
la belleza de la mujer negra la
fortaleza por eso sale una mujer negra
tocando en bagdad a tantas reinas negras
en ese vídeo como realmente son las
mujeres negras son reinas todas las
mujeres son reinas para las mujeres
negras son paradigmas de resistencia y
un sabe un factor digno mira de nuestra
sociedad
esta mujer le ha puesto pues negras
áfrica y áfrica es la cuna de la
humanidad entonces nada pero disfruten
este vídeo es pero lohan como un como
suyo y entienden ese sentido negro es el
que hace mucho
pues justamente los dejamos con la buena
música de roberto álvarez robe el niño
para finalizar este capítulo de áfrica
siete días ustedes pueden continuar con
base en esta página web france24 punto
con dos dedos más adelante con más
información quédense con nosotros
[Música]
adiós al señor no malinterprete por
favor rey más claras para el buen
entendedor hoy vengo a expresarles mis
sentidos cantando aunque no soy tenor
pero cuyo que siento con mi color y es
que yo soy negro muy rey pelé como usain
bolt como tú para bombal y sven y como
abismo rosa para erykah badu javier
sotomayor laura es que si yo soy más con
esto yo soy negro ánimo de firmeza de
valor de creatividad alegría de destreza
de sabor historia de lucha de
resistencia fuerza y honor de abbas
pueblo después tenés que gracias al
señor soy quien es
[Aplausos]